greatest of all time Pro Football Hall
of Famer Jim Brown good to see you sir
[Applause]
good to be here it's glad to have you
here
so I guess first off what did you think
of the pics that the Browns made last
night Baker Mayfield in Denzel Ward Jim
I'm a loyal person you know and I was
looking at of course getting around the
great running back and then we had four
or five different quarterbacks but would
our experts saw it a little differently
yes I think when you deal with a
defensive back that has the speed and
the quickness and you deal with a
quarterback that had those kind of
statistics and we can't really go wrong
so have you any thoughts I guess on
whether the Browns organization has
changed based on John Dorsey's arrival
here Jim I have been changing for the
better he's very positive a lot of
energy you know he relates to me and so
what can I say about him except that he
brings that kind of energy and that kind
of intelligence and he's a little
different yeah and the pick that he made
last night definitely surprised a lot of
people because mayfield despite his
exploits and positive results
collegiately jim doesn't have the height
do you have any thoughts on whether
height at the quarterback position is
something that should be discarded or or
counted upon general you would want to
have a guy about 250 you know seven feet
tall and so I'm not sure so of course
you know we like that kind of figure but
the genius of all of this is that those
people that make the decisions they
really go out and they see the things
that our guy possesses and they they
don't want the norm they want the
exception so the exception is always
going to be sure
you know any LaVon that paper washing in
the old days it wasn't even six feet if
I have my choice of having a big guy you
know I take the big Jim Brown Pro
Football Hall of Famer here on the Rich
Eisen show so what do you say to people
who think that the Browns organization
just won't get it right they can't get
it right that the Browns are going to
Browns how do you respond to something
like that Jeff and I can see very well
with my you know I'm 2015 not 2020 so I
rely upon the things that I see in the
things that I analyze or what I gave you
that really synopsis of what I thought
that was a really me talking the Browns
have had bad luck by their own fault
over many years so the general public
has a right to demand that they
understand what is going on today but I
think that the organization now with the
owner
and with a coach that we have and with
the clarity that we have we're starting
a new era and I think it's gonna be very
positive a few more minutes left here
with the Jim Brown who's been kind
enough to stop by as we close up our
show here from from Dallas what do you
mind me asking you had a meeting with
the commissioner today what are the
topics of discussion that you have with
Roger Goodell a lot of topics of the
topics that I really addressed to him is
dealing with those individuals that can
make the decision for themselves but the
league now is trying to well let's
monitor them for example I'm saying that
players you can even legislate
situations and you can talk about the
helmet but and all those things but
ultimately football is football and
you're gonna have to make decisions
based upon your quickness and what you
think you see so they were covering it
in a sense that we all had an opinion I
was trying to deal with the kneeling
rule I didn't get an answer but I think
that we do the fans and their justice
when we don't stand up for the national
anthem before the flag I've been totally
I guess yes but we had an opportunity to
talk about and I think that's the main
thing to communication so but do you
understand a couple more minutes left
here with Jim Brown that that you late
60s 70s with Muhammad Ali and Bill
Russell okay from what you stood for in
terms of social consciousness for
players and and peaceful protest for you
to say that there shouldn't be any
kneeling that folks kind of don't
understand where that would be coming
from from you please quickly we
superstars doing a day we had our secret
meeting we had a private meeting we had
our discussions we came out of those
discussions knowing exactly what our
goals were okay that's the way that we
approached it
and so the difference is that today the
situation is you have one guy taking the
knee the other players on his team and I
have taken a knee when we were united we
came out without put we're all together
so the big difference is if you got a
great work it out with your teammates in
your organization and that take a public
don't have every guy out there with an
individual position that's no you're
never gonna solve this do you think
Kaepernick should have a job in the NFL
[Applause]
I think that everybody should have a job
that qualifies but I think that there is
the thing called entrepreneurship and
ownership and investing in your business
and I tell you what I really think I
think that every player should
understand how privileged he is to be
able to have a voice notoriety and to
make all that kind of money
so if you're a player and you have that
kind of situation you should organize
your other players and then you all come
out as a unit now to directly say that
this young man should be a quarterback
everyone should have an opportunity that
has the ability his ability is
questioned to a certain degree
but if I was the general manager I would
not want to take him on because I would
not know what he's going to do and I
would always want to know what my
players are gonna do and they would come
to me first and we were discussed my
problem with him is that he has a right
to express themselves but he should not
put himself out there as it
that doesn't work I have one minute left
before the show ends the radio network
ends the show what do you think LeBron's
gonna do in a couple months Jim wants to
be a great great player for Los Angeles
you did that once upon a time didn't you
leave Cleveland for Los Angeles wants to
fer a movie career back in the day
instead you ended the movies hey Jim I
really appreciate you taking the time I
know you're gonna be part of the draft
tonight always appreciate when you take
time to be on this show in person or on
the phone all the way throughout the
years the NFL Network in here I really
do thank you Jim that means a lot that
means a ton of us that means a ton to me
Jim Brown here the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience